le reste de l'actualité cette semaine
était organisée à Bois-d'Arcy une
conférence sur l'usage d'Internet l'idée
d'améliorer les connaissances des
parents sur le sujet pour une meilleure
utilisation ensuite de l'outil par les
enfants un reportage de Nicolas dandry
et d'Osman van derday
le web est devenu ces dernières années
le canal d'information le plus utilisé
par les jeunes ils sont de plus en plus
nombreux à posséder un smartphone une
tablette et accède à Internet quel que
soit l'endroit où il se trouve c'est
pour cette raison qu'il est important de
sensibiliser les parents au risque
d'Internet déjà faut protéger son image
et puis surtout de la part des adultes
faut aider les jeunes les accompagner
les conseiller leur rappeler des choses
qui paraissent souvent logiques aux
adultes mais qui ne sont pas forcément
pour les jeunes déjà ils ont pas le
droit d'avoir de compte facebook
normalement c'est à partir de 13 ans et
après ben voilà c'est tout problème
qu'on essaye aussi un peu d'exposer avec
les parents c'est l'équipement
progressif accompagner vis-à-vis des
appareils pour poser un déjà de la part
des parents sur les usages et éviter que
les jeunes utilisent trop les outils et
sans contrôle les enfants et adolescents
sont sujets à un bombardement quotidien
de contenu à ne pas mettre devant tous
les yeux et toutes les oreilles comme
les sites pornographiques le vol
d'information personnelle ou encore des
arnaques diverses et variées car and
store qu'une mère de famille de Bois
d'Arcy est consciente de ses risques il
suffit de taper deux mots sur les
moteurs de recherche pour avoir des
pages qui s'ouvrent avec des choses qui
ne conviennent pas à leur âge donc je
trouve qu'il y a beaucoup de risques à
aller sur internet tout seul pour
l'instant on a beaucoup
l'ordinateur et on est avec eux quand
ils vont sur internet mais pas seulement
l'association y enfance préconise
d'accompagner son enfant lorsqu'il
utilise internet et surtout d'avoir un
contrôle parental discrimé efficace sur
tous les objets connectés